[Music]
we've tried to study him but he's much
too good for that you know rabbits very
clever in sending you
you are so ever his taste handsome
delicious how did it hear a quid pro quo
agent piglet first tell me what did the
hep him say to you in the next cell he
said he can smell my hocks ah I on the
other hand cannot I'd like to ask you
the question rabbit must be getting very
desperate
you know a woozle once tried to test me
I ate his stuffing but some fava beans
in a nice big pot of honey yummy yummy
in my tummy mm-hmm if you could get
their bees out you know what you look
like to me agent piglet a runt a will
scrubbed hustling runt with a little
taste good nutrition has given you some
rump to roast but you're not more than
one generation from poor soy processed
imitation bacon are you agent piglet
were you the loser at the county fair
always winning the most likely to
stutter Award dreaming of getting out
getting all the way to the Hundred Acre
Woods you see much poo there but can you
turn that high-powered perception on
yourself come on you looking for Tigger
etat tell me why do they call him that
started as a joke they said this cat
likes his kids run away little piglet
ongoing conk
[Music]
ha ha they put some lotion on its skin
or else it gets the hose again you know
my imaginations really gotten carried
away with itself it puts the lotion on
its skin or else it gets the hose again
I'm so confused a view of consciousness
even when I'm not around how does this
work just put the lotion in the fucking
basket Christopher Robin thanks weak
sorry
what does he serve by killing anger
social acceptance for sexual
frustrations no he covets that is his
nature and how do we begin to cover the
piglet we covered what we see every day
don't you feel eyes moving over your
body piglet mmm sweet candied ham oh
mama mine covers the nipples doesn't it
quid pro quo TIG for tact tell me
something about yourself
piglet my dad was grounded abroad works
well that's not kosher
quid pro quo ah sorry friend wants more
than to make other animals human it's
not them he's concerned about it's him
that's what makes him so Savage he's
also a giant talking cartoon tiger so I
can't imagine he'd be hard to find
listen kid I don't have all day here you
know mister you let me out my mom can
pay you
she is father rich really I spend all
day skipping through the woods playing
with some animals you think that sort of
white privilege comes cheap look to that
I'd rather get to some skinning oh the
wonderful thing about Christopher it's
great a wonderful treat it stops the man
and eyeball the bottom tomato defeat the
Chapra Chapra died she died she let the
blood by blood but the wonderful thing
about Chris were that I will soon be one
are you saying
can't you tell kid I'm soon gonna be a
real boy I think that's a different
Disney film would you fra league with me
I brought with me like they quiet down
there kid nice and a peeling hmm excuse
me I'm I hate to intrude but yeah kind
of busy it's just better imma look for a
little boy wait wait wait with you short
scrawny fella yes just the air brown eye
yellow shirt blue short four foot nine
British accent exactly never seen them
alright well I wouldn't be doing my job
if I didn't act if you follow up
question ever take me alive pigs well
that was unexpected
is a anyone down here hello hey get me
out of here Oh Christopher Robin no it's
Harry's money ha ha mr. Potter I'm gonna
get you out of here but right now I've
got to leave this room I'll be right
back
porkchop get me out of here Lexington
called for the lights out hey I can't
see how the lads stopped screaming
they're good yeah I'm so sorry I
couldn't be there in person but rest
assured there will be plenty of
disappointing sequels oh you need to
turn yourself in yes I'll get right on
that
really no oh I do wish we could chat
longer but I'm having an old friend for
dinner
so long piglet
now where can I get some money
you
[Music]